also thermometer ist eigentlich eine
utopie so wird es nicht mehr
ja hallo mein name ist bossert ich sitze
hier mit lisa eckhard kabarettistin und
autorin und wir machen ein kleines
philosophisches ping pong wir haben hier
in diesen pokal drin viele zitate aus
hochkultur und popkultur und wir sagen
wir ziehen jeweils einzeln sagen ob das
eine vor treffe ist oder voll daneben
möchten sie anfangen sehr gerne
wenn man das kleinste raus
sex ohne schmerz ist wie essen ohne
gewürze nach kinostart
ja ich würde hinzufügen es darf auch
psychische schmerz sein es muss nicht
immer nur der physische sein es braucht
unterwerfung und die kann innerhalb von
einem sexualakt mehrere male hin und her
waren gleicher ebene entsteht keine
erotik man wüsste ich nicht wie das
weinrote weil er werbung oder der macht
ich würde es fast synonym gebraucht man
muss seinen körper grenze aufgeben und
das ist immer etwas schmerzhaftes und
man kann dem entweder entsagen oder es
gefälligst genießen und zweiteres kann
ich nur jedem empfehlen
[Musik]
klar führe ich selbst gespräche hin und
wieder brauche ich auch einen
expertenrat unbekannt ist sie glauben ja
nicht allein selbst ich glaube nicht an
das selbst ja und ich finde experte ist
dann sehr um erotisches worden weil das
ist so lustig dass es experten nach gibt
über meint selbst die nicht ich bin
leider sind es nicht mehr die menschen
die mehr über uns wissen findet dem
psychoanalytiker dass es noch schön wenn
der meint mehr über mich zu wissen also
auch hier ja ja eben eine wahl war arabi
der sagt irgendwann werden uns die
algorithmen besser kennen als wir uns
selbst ich glaube nicht an diese dies
topische
und zeichnung dass das uns die die wehr
dass die starke ki völlig auslöschen
wird das glaube ich nicht ich glaube sie
wird uns einfach und selbst überlassen
ich glaube sie werden uns einfach alle
arbeit wegnehmen allen lebenssinn also
thermometer ist eigentlich eine utopie
so wird es nicht
[Musik]
ja schon der alte fritz jedermann hat
gerade so viel eitelkeit als es ihm am
verstand fehlt
friedrich mit
aber vielleicht war ihm
gewiss gewesen
untersuchen soll nach dem zitat wer
intelligent ist aber es ist ja auch
nicht entgangen dass ihm der verstand
abhanden kommt vielleicht hat seine
seiner selbstverliebtheit zur
übernachtung geführt also es gibt eine
eitelkeit die sich ja die sehr strebens
wert finde ja das ist auch eine
einigkeit die dem anderen gefallen
möchte das ist eine wunderbare und sehr
uneigennützige eitelkeit ich glaube die
hat er gemeint
[Musik]
realität ist eine illusion welche durch
die abwesenheit von alkohol entsteht
falco ja das ist natürlich sehr schön
ich bin der realität und illusion ist
sehr schön dass zusammenzubringen ich
also diese perspektivisch muss den sack
bei nietzsche gibt
wahrscheinlich ist dass die wahrheit als
illusion von der wir vergessen haben
dass das eine ist wir kriegen hier
wahrscheinlich nicht das mag sein ja
also ich finds aber insofern noch nicht
ob volltreffer
ist es einfach davon ist einzigartig
werden finden sie ja ich kannte ihn
nicht
das mag sein also es sind die größten
sind die man ein bisschen um sympathie
spreche also fahren
[Musik]
komme dieser art steht dann
glaubst du gott wollte dich
fragezeichen das ist die frage
welche phase sieht sie
jetzt nein nein nein jetzt ist es die
mittlere die dann von den rezipienten
bisschen vernachlässigt werden würde was
haben sie damit gemeint glaubst du gott
wollte dich da ging es um da ging es um
allergiker und das herauskehren dieser
schwäche dass man sehr sehr sehr
sensibel reagiert auf die umwelt und zu
glauben eigentlich überheblich das mache
einem zu einem höheren menschen und das
war ein damals noch sehr
grobschlächtiger aber natürlich zu dem
ich trotzdem stehe versucht die wieder
ein bisschen runter zu holen doch dass
die allergie mich auch besonders macht
und individuen mache ja schon aber man
muss unterscheiden zwischen
empfindsamkeit und empfindlichkeit also
wenn ich die welt nur abtasten nach
dingen die mich vielleicht kranken
könnten und dahingehend mein fokus
ausrichten und nicht nach dingen die
mich erfreuen könnten und so würde ich
eher die empfindsamkeit definieren da
tut man sich selbst keinen gefallen ist
weniger dass mich diese menschen
enervierend sie tun mir leid weil sie
sich so viel glück bringen ja das war s
das philosophische ping pong mit lisa
ecker hat ja danke ihnen was genau ich
danke euch für das zugucken wenn die
kommentare habt schreibt sie unten rein
und wenn ihr die ganzen sternstunde
sehen überhaupt nicht liest findet ihr
hier hier drücken